on indonesia's most populous island java
hospitals are stretched to their limits
these covert 19 patients were able to
get treatment
but many others are missing out
we have rejected so many people in our
hospital we reject patients every day
because there's nothing else we can do
for doctors having to reject critically
ill patients is a heavy burden
it makes me so sad to turn down patients
i read the files of patients who are
referred to our hospital
they can hardly breathe but we cannot
help them
the indonesian hospitals association
says hospitals on the islands of java
and bali
are close to collapse doctors are forced
to turn away patients
because of a lack of intensive care unit
beds and
a shortage of healthcare workers
indonesia's covert 19 task force says in
some cities
all hospital beds are full and health
specialists say on average more than a
quarter of people are testing positive
for the disease
across indonesia the positivity rate is
27
it's high the who standard is 5
to ensure that the pandemic can be
controlled
many have struggled to get care for
their loved ones
the emergency unit was full there was a
tent for all the positive cases but all
the rooms were full so my parents were
sent home with medication
out of desperation some families have
turned to a local covert 19 data agency
to help them get their relative into a
hospital
often it is too late
[Music]
from our cases one died in the health
center another died in a taxi after
being rejected by many hospitals
another died in hospital because the icu
was full
despite the rise in cases and deaths
indonesia's president says the situation
is under control
we're grateful that indonesia is one of
the countries that can control this
crisis well
but many health workers have criticized
the government for failing to properly
implement restrictions to stop the
spread of the virus
and allowing a crisis to unfold in their
hospitals
jessica washington al jazeera jakarta